[Musica]
benvenuti il nuovo episodio del leccio
con karim usa ma benvenuti al primo
video del 2017
e cazzo mi faccio i complimenti da solo
per esser riuscito a fare una serie di
video per un anno intero senza mollarla
ma tutto questo non avrei mai potuto
farlo senza l'aiuto della mia bellezza e
come iniziare questo nuovo anno insieme
se non con una lettera una lettera ad
aldo giovanni e giacomo
non devo certo spiegarvi io chi sia il
trio comico più famoso d'italia a parte
loro
e a parte loro e soprattutto a parte
loro potrei per esempio introdurre li
elencando i loro spettacoli teatrali i
loro film al cinema la cosa solo in una
pagina di wikipedia
no e allora di solito una lettera aperta
si indirizza direttamente al
destinatario quindi con questo vedo io
dovrei parlare direttamente con aldo
giovanni e giacomo
ma preferire invece rivolgervi a tutto
il suo pubblico perché dopo tanti anni
di attività
ce ne siamo accorti tutti il loro lavoro
ha iniziato a calare di qualità e detto
questo iniziamo dall ultimo lavoro del
trio fuga da roma park
oggi qui non voglio mentirvi non voglio
addolcirvi la pillola fuga da roma park
fa cagare la merda ma perché supposta
anni fa dicevo che non c'è peggior film
di un film comico che non fa ridere non
solo perché è difficile guardare un film
comico gru fa ridere ma è molto più
difficile spiegare i motivi per il quale
quel film comico non fa ridere
questo discorso si può fare con i film
comici che hanno delle battute degli
sketch dei momenti comici puoi dire a a
questo momento è bello questo è brutto
da ray park non ha niente non ha neanche
quel momento in cui dice oh mio dio
questa parte comica è una merda perché
non ci sono queste parti comiche ma qual
è la trama
dunque ci sono aldo giovanni e giacomo
che interpretano loro stessi ma anziani
e vengono letteralmente scaricate in
questo ospizio barra al centro per
anziani barra campo di concentramento
dove cercheranno appunto il titolo di
di fuggire basta della trama non c'è più
niente non è solo tralasciato qualche
particolare qualche sfumatura precipita
no non c'è nient'altro da raccontare del
film ma per l'amor di dio questo non è
un incipit di una trama
questo è quello che si dicono per ridere
due amici mezzi ubriachi alla notte di
capodanno
comunque loro cercano tra mille
disavventure di fuggire da questo centro
tipo steve mcqueen
non so se ve ne siete accorti anche voi
gli ultimi film di aldo giovanni giacomo
da il cosmo sul comò la banda dei babbi
natale il record poco del maggiordomo è
questo qua non si capisce più se
volessero fare un umorismo più legato al
realismo dei personaggi o sul no un
senso per esempio qui ci sono dei
dialoghi che sono molto terreni molto
normali ma poi inseriscono come
personaggio un signore con una malattia
un po specifica cioè quando parla parla
come una telecronaca calcistica che esce
fuori da una radiolina degli anni 60 che
cosa ma nel contesto fisico cosa cazzo
mi significa è il film è tutto così
dall'inizio alla fine
tra un dialogo che non ha nessun
elemento comico e non porta avanti la
trama in mezzo a tanti microelementi non
sense che stanno bene nella trama come
tirare fuori il cazzo ad un battesimo ma
la cosa buffa è che non è neanche tutto
questo l'elemento negativo per me di
questo film non fraintendetemi tutto
questo è pura merda ma non tanto quanto
quello che sto per raccontarvi in mezzo
al film ci sono più o meno un quarto
d'ora venti minuti buoni di scene prese
direttamente dagli spettacoli comici del
trio senza spiegarvelo a fondo durante
la trama loro si trovano a mettere dei
degli occhiali per la realtà virtuale
più o meno è lì dentro vedono il loro
passato ma gli sketch che loro vedono
non solo creati apposta per il film con
loro giovani che fanno qualcosa nel loro
passato sono letteralmente degli
spezzoni di vecchi spettacoli ficca
dentro la pellicola ma che cazzo sto
guardando cioè io pago alternarci ma a
vedere un film e mi ritrovo con una loro
retrospettiva è la cosa più triste di
tutta questa situazione qua è che quei
pezzi sono l'unica cosa decente del film
ma grazie al cazzo sono presi da
spettacolo e che tutti amano tutti
adorano e come se io in mezzo a questo
video dice sì
ecco questo video oggi è finito abbiamo
parlato di aldo giovanni e giacomo
ma per allietare la vostra serata è come
dire per 10 minuti per eni eni eni eni
ei folli anche solo pensare di fare una
cosa del genere al cinema è fin qui il
primo punto del video ce lo siamo levati
fuga da roma park ora vorrei cercare di
analizzare con voi uno dei possibili
motivi per cui i lavori degli ultimi
anni non siano all'altezza di quelli
vecchi perché internet ha dato
l'opportunità gente stronza come me di
poter esprimere la propria opinione ma
si è dimenticato di dire anche di
giustificare la propria opinione ogni
tanto perché è facile dire ma no perché
quelli mezzi erano più belli ti ricordi
carabinieri con le palle quadrate e
faceva ridere dr figlio di merger quello
non mica gli altri sono bene quando
eravamo senza però andare nel dettaglio
troppo facile alcuni dicono
semplicemente che abbiano per sul
talento ecco per come vedo la vita io il
talento non è una cosa che si può
perdere può capitare un periodo no in
cui tu stai seduto alla sua scrivania a
fissare un foglio bianco per mesi e non
ti viene un'idea manco se ti spari sui
[ __ ]
oppure essendo in tre e possibile che a
volte sia difficile incastrare un'idea
posso però dirvi quello che il mio
pensiero e il mio soltanto cioè le di
mick come spiegarvi che cos'è una
chimica 2
prendiamo il trailer di fuga da roma
park ve lo descrivo ci sono aldo
giovanni e giacomo che fanno tre anziani
mio dio ecco quella è stata la reazione
della stragrande maggioranza che l'ha
guardato perché fuga avere una barca è
un film di bic cioè punta su un elemento
facilone per differenziarsi dagli altri
cioè l'elemento facciamo tre anziani per
come vedo io la comicità fare tre
personaggi normali affrontare i problemi
normali in modo comico è molto più
interessante che fare delle maschere per
esempio le chimiche vengono spiegate
molto bene nell'ambito wrestling quando
tu vedi un nuovo lottatore entrare che
ha solo una mutande degli stivali sei
molto interessato a capire cosa farà
perché non ha nessuna di mick che lo
differenzia dagli altri
mentre se tu vedi entrare per esempio un
clown sai già dove potrebbe andare a
parare
perché un cazzo di clown quindi avrà il
naso che suona le scarpe giganti la
trombetta ecco questi tipi di film di
mick di aldo giovanni giacomo ti fanno
perdere d'interesse perché si anticipano
quello che succederà perché porca
miseria allora prendiamo i due
spettacoli più famosi di aldo giovanni e
giacomo
i corti e tali che il peluche cosa mi
ricordo gli uni sti spettacoli mi
ricordo loro seduti a guardare il loro
spettacolo quello sketch e oro invece il
conte dracula mi ha fatto sempre cagare
mi ricordo perfettamente a memoria la
subaru baracca mentre secondo me dr
figlio di come non è invecchiato molto
bene e così per i film per me il loro
film perfetto e chiedimi se sono felice
perché sono loro stessi in situazioni
comiche realistiche mentre il cosmo sul
comò mi ha fatto cagare perché ma che
cazzo di idea è questa che cazzo di idee
sono queste però vedete anche il cosmo
sul como è un piccolo universo lì dentro
ci sono sketch terribili come quello dei
quadri e sketch buoni come quello della
dottoressa castani frizzi perché perché
sono personaggi realistici in un
contesto cosa avete capito
e qui riprendendo fuga da roma park è un
film gimmick con loro tre anziani quella
non è una buona idea
pensa e come se a un certo punto della
vita a loro avessero detto oh mio dio
abbiamo fatto uno degli spettacoli più
belli della storia della comicità i
corti di aldo giovanni e giacomo
e sai qual'è lo sketch più bello di
tutti gli animali
ecco gli animali e lo sketch più bello
di tutti sai cosa dovremmo fare dovremmo
fare un film come un concept simile bob
fuga da roma park tutto anche questo
secondo punto ne rimane soltanto 1
finale e questo è un pochino delicato
questa è martina e la mia compagna di
vita
io l'amo l'adoro le voglio un bene
dell'anima ma non la farei mai recitare
il mio video perché nonostante io lami
così tanto che morirei per lei
io so che lei non sa recitare in modo
comico punto detto questo silvana io
sono sicurissimo che silvana sia una
persona straordinaria e che sia di una
compagnia incredibile che se ci andassi
a cena morirei dalle risate dall'inizio
alla fine ne sono sicuro però mi
dispiace dirtelo silvana mi dispiace
dirlo anche ad aldo silvana attualmente
è la costante su cui tutto il vostro
pubblico è d'accordo non funziona mai in
nessun ruolo
sono sicurissimo che per la legge dei
grandi numeri a qualcuno piacerà sono
sicuro e va bene che poi mica un
problema solo di silvana io io io voglio
bene a roberto però la nicoletta io lo
so che voi avete la memoria scolastica
di com'era la vita è bella
e ancora un grandissimo film ma provate
a guardarlo adesso
dio pietà ma che non sia vero un'altra
cena dal prefetto perché viene che tua
madre
tom araya per l'amor di dio quindi vi
prego aldo giovanni e giacomo
non fate la fine di roberto che poi ha
smesso di fare film e magari andate a
teatro o su raidue a leggere che ne so
l'orlando furioso e nella nostra
comicità muore lì in diretta televisiva
per favore si può rimediare ma a parte
le stronzate proviamo a dare una
chiusura questa lettera a voi trio
comico delle meraviglie vi dico che la
gente ancora adesso vi ad ora e per
quello che è molto critica con i vostri
lavori soprattutto su internet perché
vorrebbe vedervi all'apice della vostra
carriera ancora adesso non è vero che
avete perso il talento perché non si può
perdere il talento fate finta voi tre di
essere dei cecchini un cecchino esperto
non manca mai il bersaglio ma può
sbagliare bersaglio che è quello che
secondo me state facendo voi voi state
sbagliando soggetto sia per il teatro
sia per i film guarda faccio il pezzo di
merda e provo io da questo ufficio
freddo io sto gelando in questo momento
uno stronzo qualsiasi un signor nessuno
che la gente ascolta soltanto perché fa
video da dieci anni
mi piacerebbe provare ad azzardare un
consiglio appunto essendo dieci anni che
faccio video quando li scrivo ho capito
una cosa che quando hai un idea a volte
questa idea è molto meglio raccontarla
direttamente senza filtri come se la
stessi raccontando a voce ad un tuo
amico piuttosto che raccontarla in uno
sketch con un copione dei personaggi è
un concetto da prima elementare ma a
volte lo si dimentica in certe
situazioni funziona molto di più puntare
alla semplicità delle cose piuttosto che
complicarsi la vita e far uscire una
merda
sono stracontento di aver finalmente
fatto questo video che avevo in mente da
un sacco di tempo contentissimo di
iniziare un nuovo anno dello show
insieme a voi un enorme abbraccio e
saluto ad aldo
anni già come non vi preoccupate come ho
detto prima la gente mi ama
un saluto karim